ja nochmal willkommen zum zweiten Teil
des ersten Tages ich hatte auf den
letzten Folien ihn präsentiert ein paar
neuere forschungsthesen die besagten das
virtuelle Realität in unserem Alltag
angekommen ist dass es nicht mehr nur
etwas
eskapistisches ist was sowas wie
weltflug bedeutet sondern dass virtual
Realität immer Zentrale für unseren
Alltag wird und in diesem Sinne gibt es
einen neuen SBB also
Sonderforschungsbereich der den Titel
trägt virtuelle Lebensmittel und der
seine Ruhe Universität Bochum
angesiedelt
dieser Sonderforschungsbereich der
betont das virtuelle Realität
sind eine treibende Kraft für
gesellschaftliche kulturelle
Informationsprozesse darstellen dass das
virtuelle zwischen längste Teil unseres
Alltag ist
und man sieht jetzt hier auf der
nächsten Grafik dass ich das ganz schön
aus dieser man sieht also hier es gibt
Info digital virtuelle Infrastrukturen
dann virtuelles Wissen Körper und Raum
und Interaktion spielten eine Rolle
meine Vorlesung betrifft auch einige
dieser Punkte
obwohl sie eben stärker ein
philosophischen Fokus drauf legt diese
Sonderforschungsbereich ist
interdisziplinär dabei ganz verschiedene
Disziplinen mit
Naturwissenschaft Kulturwissenschaft die
Philosophie meines Wissens nicht
expliziert wird und das ist natürlich
eine gute Anlass hier in diese
Forschungslücke vorzustoßen ja also
seine Philosophie der virtuellen
Realität gibt es in diesem umfassenden
Bereich der diese ganzen verschiedenen
Aspekte betrachtet nicht
obwohl es natürlich Bücher gibt und ich
werde ihn auch nachher noch einen
vorstellen die schon 90er Jahren
geschrieben wurden die solche Titel
tragen wie immer reality
also Metaphysik der virtuellen Realität
mit der Physik ist eine philosophische
Disziplin also es gibt durchaus schon
Bücher auf dem Markt die vorgeben
virtuelle Realität aus philosophischer
Perspektive zu behandeln häufig handelt
es sich dann aber nicht wirklich um eine
Metaphysik also strengen Sinne oder
Ontologie die diese Fragen betrifft die
wir jetzt wollen diskutiert haben im
ergänzt Konstruktion sondern es handelt
sich eher um eine Sicht auch virtuelle
Realität die diese als eine Form von
Kultur erfasst als eine sehr
realistische Form von Erfahrung aber in
nur realistisch und nicht real,-
so und jetzt habe ich schon angekündigt
es gibt einen neuen das heißt 9 ja ein
Film der fünf Jahre alt ist das jetzt
neu der altes müssen sie beurteilen wenn
wir jetzt nur eine modephilosophie hier
machen würden müsste ich sagen das ist
schon veraltet dafür fünf Jahre ist ja
was wurde angelangt mit ziemlich lange
Zeit
wer von ihnen hat schon mal ready Player
one gesehen einfach mal melden also noch
nicht so viele ist das wird sogar
vielleicht sogar gut weiter nicht alle
alles wissen und wir schauen uns jetzt
mal einen Clip an sozusagen kurze ja
Zusammenfassung und Sequenz aus diesem
Film und wir schauen uns die natürlich
an unter bestimmten Leitfragen und die
zeige ich Ihnen jetzt als wir fragen sie
fragen sich bitte auch zuschauen und
Zuschauer auf Youtube wie wird in dem
Filmausschnitt den wir jetzt gleich
sehen aus ready Player one Realität mit
virtueller Realität und kontrastiert
achten Sie wie Realität dargestellt oder
das was Realität sein soll als
Hintergrundfolie und schauen Sie wie vor
diesem Hintergrund virtuelle Realität
inszeniert wird und wie sie auch
bewertet wird von dem Erzähler den sie
gleich hoffentlich laut genug hören
inwiefern ist die dargestellte virtuelle
Realität real fragen sie sich ist sie
nur realistisch oder ist die ontologisch
signifikant
und genauso kann man sich fragen
inwiefern ist die dargestellte Realität
also die Hintergrundfolie vor der sich
dann die virtuelle Realität eröffnet
oder abzeichnet oder abheben inwiefern
ist die Reha und wie können wir die als
real bewertet und dann noch eine Frage
die natürlich auch ganz wichtig ist mit
welchen Medien wird in diesem Ausschnitt
virtuelle Realität inszenieren also
welche Medien welche Geräten welche
Techniken sind beteiligt dass so etwas
wie virtuelle Realität real,-
um gemeinsam diese Fragen zu diskutieren
jetzt hoffe ich dass es klappt
ja wir haben sehr ergiebig die
diskutiert über diese Fragen wir haben
gesehen dass
alle
realitätszugänge
medial Mittel sind es ist vielleicht ein
bisschen doppelt gemoppelt Medium heißt
ja Vermittlung also Vermittlung ist ganz
wichtig durch die Brillen wir haben
gesehen dass die dystopische Realität
diese
schrottrealität dass die mit anderen
filmischen Mitteln wieder Mittel
inszeniert wird und dann eben auch noch
eine wichtige Beobachtung dass dieses
Gamification Moment eine große Rolle
spielte Spiel wir haben gesehen dass es
ein Vergleich zum Netflix gibt
die virtuelle Realität stärker Rücken
ist eigentlich physische Realität weil
das
eigenständig verloren werden
E-Commerce zu tun leicht auch vom
petitiven Sinne wir haben auch gesehen
dass diese
Unordnung der Dystopie eine gewisse
Ordnung trotz allem aufweist und wir
haben gesehen dass in der Eingangsszene
eine Art von Bezug zu Platons Höhe
Gleichnis gegeben
die hat den Titel Oasis eine Oase ist
natürlich in der Wüste ein begehrtes
Ziel aber
er sind nur Illusionen und diese
ambivalenzte Oase finde ich auch immer
im Hinterkopf behalten so viel dazu noch
viel sagen das ist dann dieser Kernsatz
die Space reality
heutzutage kannst du die Realität
vergessen
jeder versucht ihr zu entkommen
[Musik]
unbefriedigende Situation die sind alle
frustriert in dieser Realität
ja jetzt kann man sich ein paar Fragen
stellen ist virtuelle Realität dasselbe
wie Realitätsflucht hat jetzt nicht
bezogen auf ready Player once auf
unseren Begriff von virtuitiv es wird
wieder Realität dasselbe die
realitäts-flucht aus der Dystopie wenn
Sie Ihre Brille aufsetzen wir können
sich gerne melden noch nicht so viele
ich habe meine studieren immer gefragt
warum haben sie keine Brille zu teuer ja
die beginnt ja auch so 300 €. jetzt
kommt im Herbst Abschluss Quest 3 raus
und dann ist jetzt schon angekündigt
und auch da wollte ich Sie darauf
hinweisen wir schauen uns nachher da
auch ein werbetrieb dieser Moment wo die
Person die Brille aufsetzt hat genau
dieselbe Kameraführung wie in ready
Player one da verschmelzen dritte Person
Perspektive
ganz interessante
wenn sie jetzt seine aufsetzen machen
aus der dystopischen Realität oder warum
würden sie das tun
gleich noch ein bisschen diskutieren das
machen wir jetzt vielleicht gleich ich
will doch trotzdem diese ja doch ich
lass es mal dabei und wir diskutieren
auf die Frage warum sollten heutzutage
überhaupt keine Brille aufsetzen
ja wir haben uns die Frage gestellt ob
virtuelle Realität so wie es uns heute
begegnen und wie sich angepriesen wird
vermarktet wird ob die Realitätsflucht
darstellt bei ready Player one
schien es so der Fall sein heutzutage
sagen viele mit Recht das ist keine
Realität sondern damit kann ich tolle
Dinge tun die in der Realität auch
machen kann nur vielleicht andere Weise
zum Beispiel kann ich machen die Wirkung
der Effektes Ziel ist genau dasselbe ich
kann es noch andere Weise erreichen wenn
wir uns Sequenzen anschauen Videos
anschauen wo man Menschen mit so einer
wie auch Brille sieht von außen hat man
oft das Gefühl das ist eine fast schon
autistische Aktivität ja die Person die
dreht sich nur um sich selbst wie so
eine Blase in einen eigenen Welt in der
die Person sich aufhält und da werden
wir nicht so schnell genau
Realität ist einfach vielleicht auch ein
individueller Drogen tritt das sagen
manche dass das virtuelle Realität
zeigen
wenn wir dann sehen dass die Person die
da die Pille auf hat und die immersiv in
ihrer künstlichen Welt steckt wenn die
dann plötzlich angetippt wird dann
erschrickt die häufig furchtbar das
heißt wir müssen auch immer die
Perspektiven auseinanderhalten erste
Person Perspektive ist ganz wichtig für
diese Technologie in der
wirtschaftlichen Realität und die dritte
Person Perspektive Leute zurück oder
lässt sich sogar manchmal seltsam
erscheinen wenn man schaut was sie dafür
gehst zum Ausführen die nur aus den
Perspektive sind wenn man dieses Spiel
mit dem Licht
anschaut und Personen lassen eine Brille
praktizieren dann kann man von außen nur
sagen was es ist von unsinniges
sehr wichtig zumindest bei diesen
Technologien die wir momentan virtuelle
Realität nennen ist natürlich Realität
eine Verstopfung unserer Welt und falls
ja wozu sagt warum sollten wir unsere
Welt bedeuten nehmen Sie mal das so
kann ich mir eigene Unternehmen ganz
eigenen Unternehmen
ich kann mein eigenes Unternehmen im
metabären fortführen ich kann virtuelle
Gegenstände auch Modeartikel energies
Nordrhein
kann ich kaufen warum sollte ich einen
virtuellen Gegenstand von Adidas kaufen
wenn ich ihn doch nicht an meinem Körper
tragen kann ist es nicht eine
Verdopplung die doch eigentlich nur eine
Geldmacherei ist ja jetzt können sie
nicht mehr ihre Schuhe in der wirklichen
physischen kaufen dann verkauft man Zeit
in der BILD hauptsache man hat noch ja
ähm diese Frage nach der verdoppeln ist
ganz entscheidend wie verhalten sich
physische Realität ist die virtuelle
Realität nur eine virtuelle Verdoppelung
also
physische adidas Schuhe virtueller die
dazu NFC und Anfang oder ist es sehr
Erweiterung Welt zu lassen
und in diese Richtung geht natürlich
oder ersetzt vielleicht sogar die
virtuellen
sowie eine distrophie verlassen werden
kann als escape als als Zuflucht wir
haben also drei Möglichkeiten bezüglich
physische Realität
verdoppelt die physische Realität ja
zweiten sie erweitert nur
physische Realität und drittens sie
ersetzt die physische Realität es gibt
also drei wir diskutieren gleich darüber
es gibt drei Möglichkeiten mindestens
vielleicht gibt sogar
[Musik]
diese Frage habe ich aufgeworfen ist
virtuelle Realität nur eine Erweiterung
unsere Welt und jetzt machen wir noch
mal kurz eine kleine Diskussion
ja wir haben gesehen wie sich diese
verschiedenen Formen zueinander
verhalten physische virtuelle Realität
wir müssen natürlich noch eine Frage
stellen lässt sich alles der physischen
Realität die Realität nennen überhaupt
virtualisieren oder gibt es auch Grenzen
der virtualisierbarkeit das ist dann
aber natürlich eine ontologische Frage
die wir morgen diskutieren werden können
wir Leiblichkeit Situation wir können
wir virtualisieren z.B wenn wir
digitalisieren das papierfreie Büro das
ist ein wunderbarer Fortschritt der
leider im Deutschen noch viel zu wenig
beachtet wird in Deutschland sind wir da
leider ziemlich hinterher wenn es um
alle Formulare geht die man da ausfüllen
muss auch wenn es darum geht dass man
manchen Geschäften immer noch ein paar
bezahlen muss Menschen
da regelmäßig die Köpfe darüber ich bin
jetzt weg darüber kann man sich
natürlich streiten über allem
Deutschland hinterher
dass die digitale Transformation
anbelangt jetzt kann man sich fragen
kann man zum Beispiel durch das Medium
der Digitalisierung alles physische was
wir in unserem normalen Realität bisher
virtualisieren sprich ins nicht
körperliche vielleicht digitale
überführen das ist eine spannende Frage
gerade wenn es auch menschliche
Interaktion geht wenn es um
Körperlichkeit gehen Leiblichkeit geht
sagen viele da hat die Virtualität
eine natürliche Grenz darüber werden wir
aber dann auch genau diskutieren so
jetzt möchte ich sie mal fragen nachdem
wir uns jetzt hier viele Gedanken
gemacht haben nachdem wir auch Filme uns
angeschaut haben
was ist für Sie virtuelle Realität da
möchte ich jetzt die einfach mal bitten
mir gewisse Dinge zu nennen wir sagen
jetzt einfach mal und ich zeige Ihnen
danach und den Zuschauern auf YouTube
ein paar repräsentative Ergebnisse die
bei einer anderen Umfrage zu tragen kann
ja wenn wir uns mal überlegen was
virtuelle Realität ist ganz vom
Alltagsverständnis herkommend haben wir
folgende Ergebnisse ich bringe ihn mal
die Ergebnisse einer nicht
repräsentativen Umfrage wir haben doch
bezeichnet sind ich möchte ein paar
dieser Assoziation hervorheben
Simulation ne
perfekte Simulation
verbunden aber auch nicht echte Realität
es ist nur virtuellen Realität nicht die
echte also häufig kommt das Wort
virtuell im Verbund mit nur
aber nicht wirklich
und Fake
und natürlich wie april das solche
Brille
simulierte Welt es ist nicht richtig es
ist immer so
künstlich wird genannt abwesen
Schwindelgefühl sagen manche bekommen
Sie wenn Sie diese Brillen haben
Digitalisierung verbindet sich nicht
Digitalisierung echt
Fake technische Probleme also das
technische ist künstliche Computer und
ganz interessant Widerspruch ja warum
hat jetzt
und es ist diese unterlogical confusion
von der dieses Oxford Handbook
gesprochen hat die ontologische
Konfusion kommt daher dass wir
einerseits haben es ist eine virtuelle
Realität ist also wirklich Realität ist
ja Wirklichkeit aber es ist ja nur
virtuelle Realität also die nicht
wirklich Wirklichkeit und das ist
natürlich ein Widerspruch wenn wir so
sehen ja und anhand dieser verschiedenen
Intuitionen die bei uns begrifflich
vielleicht auch in der Abstände Gefühle
verursachen können wenn wir diesen
Begriff so und uns ansehen wollen wir
jetzt im Folgenden etwas mehr einsteigen
versuchen philosophische Klärung zu
schaffen ich möchte jetzt trotzdem noch
Lebenswelt ein paar
ökonomischen interessierte
Repräsentationen oder Präsentation von
virtuelle Realität vorstellen zunächstes
Metall wäre so
diese Werbeanzeige habe ich im Spiegel
mal gelesen vor so einem
Herbst glaube ich 2022 kam das
im Metapher Summen werden Studierende
noch tiefer in die Materie eintauchen
können also sie die Sie gerade hier
sitzen uns hier die sie auf Youtube
vielleicht zuschauen das Wetter wäre
positiven Einfluss auf die Bildung haben
deshalb helfen wir es auch zu bauen
Naturwissenschaften werden Studierende
virtuelle Zellen dieses kleinste Teil
untersuchen und immer gerne das metabär
so jetzt kommt mag nur virtuell sein nur
virtuell aber es wird einen realen
Einfluss so wird jetzt hier virtuelle
Realität Zustand es ist nur
[Musik]
aber es hat immerhin einen Einfluss auf
die Realität auch wenn es nicht real ist
immerhin bewegt sich irgendwie auf die
Realität
und jetzt möchte ich dass philosophische
problematisieren und Fragen sind
Realität und Virtualität tatsächlich
Gegensätze also sind die auf derselben
Ebene so wie wir sagen können etwas ist
echt oder nicht
sind die beiden Begriffe so zu verstehen
oder es Virtualität eher ein Prädikat
von werden als eine Form die Realität
annehmen kann dass sie sagen wir mal
physisch sein kann aber auch nutril sein
vielleicht sogar noch was anderes und
ich möchte von ihm gerade für diese Zeit
Option eine Tieren Virtualität und
Realität nicht auf derselben Ebene als
sagen wir mal als
Subjekte anzusehen die den etwas
reduziert werden kann zumindest nicht
Virtualität als Subjekt anziehen
im Sinne des Satzglied sondern als
Prädikat
Virtualität ist ein Prädikat sowie
Grünheit Grün zu sein ja so kann etwas
virtuells
natürlich kann auch etwas Reals sein
aber Virtualität spezifiziert Realität
und tritt nicht als Subjekt gegen
die Realität so dass sie irgendwie
geraten
weil Virtualität nur ein Prädikat
nämlich eine Form eine Eigenschaft von
Realität ist so meine Thesen und das
wollen wir jetzt noch genauere Folge
natürlich ausführlich uns anschauen bei
Morgen wenn es um Onkologie geht möchte
natürlich auch noch mal ein bisschen ein
Beispiel reality geben und da habe ich
jetzt einfach ganz tolles Beispiel
schauen Sie mal hier
durchlaufen
Situation das Kind nicht weg wenn es ein
wirklicher Elefant werden
[Musik]
ist ja nur ja was sind
wird schwierig gell
zumindest Elefanten Simulationen der
wird simuliert und er wird als
Simulation in die physische Realität
integriert
manche sagen das sei jetzt ein
virtueller oder Augmented Reality so
wir sind schwierig schauen wir mal eine
andere schöne Situationen
Insel da ist Schildkröte Unterschrift
Einheit geschrieben
gleich nach dieser Schildkröten und zwar
gleich die Vorführung
das kann man sich anschauen und jetzt
möchte ich noch mal diesen Werbung von
Virtual Reality wenn man sich vorstellt
also man sieht das aus und man sieht auf
dem T-Shirt wenn sich nichts gefangen
plötzlich Figuren die selbst noch aktiv
werden ich spätestens ein paar Mal vor
der Tisch ist leer und jetzt ziehen Sie
die Brille auf und plötzlich befindet
sich da was drauf und Sie können damit
interagieren und diese Uhr bewegen sich
sowas kommt nicht vorbei
wäre
auf Youtube das mit perversen als als
Erwachsene Tisch erweitern
schauen Sie mal jeder sollte bestimmt
schon mal virtuellen oder auch Menschen
reality Tischtennis spielen so sieht es
aus
das sehen sie haben sich teilweise
erwartet das Mädchen ist jetzt ein
Avatar und jetzt ist es echt der Mann
ist jetzt ein Avatar und vielleicht ist
er echt ja also
[Musik]
auch echte Person
mit der Erweiterung zu verstehen und
auch die Personen die daran teilnehmen
die werden auch im Sinne Mixed Reality
so spricht man auch manchmal gemischte
Realität als Avatare und als physische
Personen
einbezogen ich will ihn eben nur so ein
paar Beispiele geben hier noch mal eins
das ist eine Form von Spiel auch so ähm
sie sehen hier sie haben hier ein
künstliche Intelligenz
haben hier rechts die haben sie jemand
eingeblendet als Fotograf
ja also Interaktion und Repräsentation
vor allem auch Präsenz Präsenz wird im
virtuellen oder in dieser vermischen
Augmented Reality ganz schön komplex
auch dadurch dass wir jetzt künstlich
Akteure mit ins Spiel
so jetzt habe ich ihn schon langes
versprochen jetzt kommt noch die
europäischen hoch ich darf dazu sagen
ich mache hier keine schleichwerfen ja
also da keine Sorge diese Brille sieht
viel zu teuer aber Apple ist eben in
vielerlei Hinsicht kommerziell getrieben
der
Vorläufer der Pacemaker viele
technologische Entwicklungen die dann am
Ende tatsächlich in unserem Alltag
Einzug finden wie z.B die Smartphones ja
durch diese intuitive bedienbar eines
Prinzip des tittens versus in andere
Prinzipien die sich nicht durchsetzen
kann ist da schon immer Ton angegeben
ästhetisch aber auch funktioniert
deswegen finde ich müssen wir uns diese
Brille machen und wie immer möchte ich
Ihnen vorher ein paar Arbeitskräfte
wie wird in dem Werbevideo was wir
gleich sehen
zweite Frage wie verhalten sich Realität
und virtuelle Realität zueinander
und schließlich zu welchem Zweck wird
virtuelle Realität konzipiert wozu wenn
es virtuelle Realität ist sie sehen die
Begriffe sind immer Strategie wozu kommt
das jetzt hier ein Spiel was bringt uns
das anders gefragt warum sollten wir uns
diese Brille kaufen ne es geht am Ende
auch bei uns kaufen so die wollen wir
uns jetzt anschauen und jetzt spiele ich
das Ganze ab bitte machen Sie sich
Notizen wir gehen dann nachher in die
gemeinsame Diskussion
ja wir haben jetzt uns eine längere
werbe sind angesehen nicht aus
kommerziellen Gründen sondern aus
philosophischen Gründen weil wir uns
jetzt gleich nach der kurzen Pause
gemeinsam überlegen wollen wie ich
Aspekte von virtuelle Realität hier
adressiert werden natürlich
kommerziellen und ästhetischen Gründen
dann diskutieren wir nach der kurzen
Pause weiter
ja wir haben uns jetzt diesen Werbeclip
angeschaut
sehr imposant ästhetisch
erzeugend für den ein und die andere
vielleicht gewesen jetzt wollen wir eben
nicht nur fragen ob wir uns jetzt nach
diesem werbetrieb und diese glaub ca
3.500 € kaufen wollen oder werden oder
würden
[Musik]
Video ist natürlich Realität verhandelt
wird wie sie angepriesen wird wie sie ja
konzipiert wird haben sie dazu
Überlegung
die wir jetzt uns hier gemeinsam
überlegen können natürlich erst dann
wieder wenn ich die Aufzeichnung
sprochen ja wir haben gesehen
Pro hat ganz viel interessante Aspekte
einmal ist wichtig der Begriff des
nahtlosen reibungslosen sieben
dann ist ein wichtiger Punkt der der
Transparenz anders als bei anderen wie
April sehen wir durch die Brille durch
wir sehen die Augen derjenigen Person
auch wenn natürlich die auch nicht wie
durch ein Glas gesehen werden sind die
Augen sind selbst medial wir sind
natürlich auch gefilmt auch die nach
außen transportiert werden aber die
Transparenz ist schon mal wichtig man
könnte sonst denken seine Art
fensterlose Monade bei Leibnitz wo
praktisch
nach außen schauen aber doch koordiniert
sind und hier ist es jetzt plötzlich ein
Fenster Wasser was aber eben doch wieder
interessanterweise medial vermittelt ist
ganz wichtige weitere Punkt ist das
Computer
das eben der Raum auch eingezogen wird
und zwar der Raum aber auch der Körper
der eigene Leib man verzichtet auch
äußere Controller wie man sie eben auch
bei anderen wie abgehen findet sein die
Gestensteuerung die Hände der Körper
selbst wird zum Medium zum
steuerungsmedium selbst wird mit der
virtuellen Realität vermittelt das ist
sicherlich auch im Sinne der Augmented
Reality entspannende Eigenschaften und
natürlich auch noch die ästhetische
Formgebung und die Sensorik sind hier
zur betonen ja also die Frage ist
natürlich ob man sowas braucht aber ich
denke schon dass Apple und Meta nicht
ohne Grund virtuelle Realität setzen sie
sehen schon was in Zukunft gebraucht
wird zu mal wie wir auch gesehen haben
wenn man so ein universalinstrument
diese Brille hat seine nächste
Generation des Smartphones hat wenn man
das Smartphone konsequent fortsetzt das
Smartphone Medium Taschenrechner Kamera
Telefon alles mögliche Größe und so
weiter wenn man das Konzentrieren diese
Eigenschaften eben auch die Brille
aufgenommen werden die dann uns alles
noch näher vermittelt unmittelbar und
wir nicht mehr auf ein externes Display
schauen müssen sondern das Display schon
in unser normale Sichtfeld integriert
bekommen wobei eben auch das normale
sichtbar wie wir gesehen haben wiederum
vermittelt ist durch die sension ja so
viel kann man sagen es ist ein
interessante fortführende Smartphones
man darf gespannt sind ob sich das
durchsetzt aber ich glaube man hat hier
noch einiges zu erwarten diesen großen
Unternehmen ja so viel dazu jetzt möchte
ich nachdem wir hier ganz konkrete
Beispiele uns angeschaut haben auch
natürlich komischen interessierter
Perspektive das muss man immer dazu
sagen möchte ich Ihnen jetzt zum
Abschluss noch ein bisschen knallharte
und ökonomische Begriffsgeschichte auch
Tischen ich hoffe sie sehen mir das nach
aber wir haben jetzt ein bisschen
Entspannung sinnliche
Wahrnehmung jetzt sollten begriffliche
nicht so selbst anschauliche gehen
der Begriff der virtuellen Realität hat
eine komplexe Begriffsgeschichte genauer
genug der Begriff der Virtualität also
betrifft jetzt noch die modale Fragen
nicht die ontologische die geht und die
Realität häufig wurde Virtualität als
optische Illusion verstanden das ist die
neuzeitliche Begriffsverwendung da kommt
Fake Illusion Simulation kommt da rein
aber es gibt eine ältere und es ist
Virtualität als Kraft das ist die Antike
und die mittelalterliche Tradition ich
versuche ihn jetzt mal zu belegen ich
glaube das stimmt man muss diese zwei
Tradition auseinanderhalten
und jetzt ist ganz interessant mit dem
auch kommen und der perversiven
verbreitet der alltäglichen Verbreitung
der neuen Medien ist die
disruptionsthese dass die
Digitalisierung was Neues ist hat
gewinnt der zweite Sinn nämlich
Virtualität als Kraft immer mehr ange
trunken hat wir sind immer mehr geneigt
zu meinem Käse diese neue Medien die
sich virtuelle Realität nehmen
immer mehr als ontologischen Faktor als
realitätshaltig ansehen
denn als bloße Simulation und Illusion
das geht auch ganz da Chor mit dieser
Feststellung des Handbuchs Virtualität
das wären zum Ende des 20 Jahrhunderts
virtuelle Realität oder das was man
virtuelle Realität nimmt noch eher den
Charakter von sk-pismus hatte
experimentell was dann eher in Richtung
optische Illusion gehen optisches
Experiment
wahrnehmungsexperiment das ist jetzt an
im ersten Viertel des 21 Jahrhundert
immer mehr als Kraft sichtbar wird wir
können damit viel tun wir können neues
tun und das heißt unsere Vermögen werden
erweitert unser Gesichtsfeld wird dabei
unsere Kommunikationsvermögen werden
erweitern
virtuelle Realität wird immer mehr als
eine Realität eigenen Rechts sichtbar
die von der bloßen
illusionssimulation geschieden ist wir
sind immer weniger Geleit zu sagen das
ist ja nur eine Simulation ist ja nur
eine Illusion
die müssen immer mehr geneignet das hat
er kausale Relevanz das ist vielleicht
nicht nur kausalrelevant sind das ist
eine eigene Kausalität und eine eigene
Realität eben eine virtuelle Realität es
muss man sich natürlich fragen wie kann
man das wieder mit dem Beispiel des
Geldes in Verbindung bringen wir hatten
ja gesehen Geld Banknoten sind
beispielhafte Frauen virtuelle Realität
ist schon vor diesen neuen Medien gab
was verbindet die Banknoten wenn sie
Form von virtuelle Realität sind und
diese neuen Medien wenn wir sie auch
zurecht virtuelle Realitäten diese Frage
wollen wir uns morgen ausführlicher
stellen
also virtuelle Realität muss erstmal von
Simulation
unterschieden werden obwohl sie Momente
davon enthält ich gebe jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen also wir müssen wirklich
auf diese anderen Formen beziehen das
hat immer was simulativolog
virtuelle Realitäten simulieren nach
diesem starken Verständnis als
kraftwirtschaftskraft nicht nur die
Realität sie simulieren sie auch und
nicht nur sondern erzeugen neue
Realitäten die von der physischen
Realität verschieden sind obwohl sie
auch mit ihrem Sinne der augmente
Realität kombiniert werden können diese
neuen Realitäten sind flexibler
vernetzter und interaktiven
dennoch sind diese virtuellen Realitäten
kausal wirksam es kommt vom Begriff
lateinisch
krafttüchtigkeit 1000 Tauglichkeit
Tugend lateinisch steckt ja der Begriff
des Mannes dahinter wird soll aber nicht
heißen das nicht auch Frauen genauso gut
unter genauso tüchtig genauso tauglich
und genauso kräftig sein kann ist
einfach jetzt nur begriffsgeschichtlich
Wortgeschichte
virtuelle Realitäten eröffnen wie
Fiktionen neue Möglichkeiten neue
Möglichkeiten doch realisieren
öffnen Möglichkeit das könnte so sein
Science Fiction oh das könnte so sein
das wäre toll
aber es noch nicht verwirklicht wenn Sie
mit dem Begriff nur
virtuelle Realitäten realisieren diese
Fiktionen das wäre jetzt mal
virtuelle Realitäten sondern ein
bisschen rückblickend gab es auch schon
vor dem Aufkommen der neuen Medien diese
langer bloodline diese Blutlinie die
sich da zurückgebrochen lässt sagt das
Oxford Hamburg gab es schon vorkommen
der neuen Medien zum Beispiel Banknoten
gehen und das wäre jetzt meine
kontinuitätsthesen das virtuellen es
gibt dazu auch Wasser durch die neuen
Medien kommt da jetzt eine kommt da was
neues im Spiel mit der virtuellen
Realität oder gab es die virtuelle
Realität gab es virtuelle Realität auch
schon
der neue Medien und ich behaupte es gab
schon davor nämlich so lange ist
Währungen gibt Geld
ja ich habe hier so ein paar Beispiele
virtuelle Realität bedeutet eine andere
realisierungsweise bereits bestehende
Phänomen
nicht und das kann auch zu einer
Transformation oder einer disruption im
disruption wissen Sie was disruption
heißt das heißt einfach eine Revolution
in der Technologie oder in bestimmten
Praktiken das etwas Altes abgelöst wird
und zwar eben doch recht
abrupt ja
heißt auch zerrütten und sie sehen das
zum Beispiel ganz interessant an den
analogen Fotos analogen Filme sie sahen
das auch an lange Zeit bei dem
Schellackplatten bei den Schallplatten
es gibt aber immer wieder Revival Moment
also so lieb habe Phänomen dass man
plötzlich wieder Schallplattenläden an
allen Ecken entstehen sicher es gibt
eben diese liebhaben dieses Rettung es
gibt auch also sind aber eben nicht mehr
technologisch jetzt kommen sondern eher
ähm retrospektiv Liebhaberei aber
technologisch ist ganz klar die die CD
der Schallplatte überlegen da gibt's
ganz klar Objektiv unter dazu weil sie
eine Liebhaber jetzt kann man das kann
man jetzt virtualisieren also ich kann
eine Banknote virtualisieren zu einem
Online mehr ich virtualisiere sie weil
ich unabhängig mich mache von dem Papier
von der Papierbasis eine Online-Werbung
hat keine materielle Basis mehr sie wird
vielleicht irgendwie instanziert oder
erzeugt durch hart aber das ist nicht
die Basis vergleichbar mit einem Papier
dann papierschalen und den Wert des
50€. ich kann auch ein physisches
Universität Seminar
virtualisieren indem ich einen
virtuelles digital sind zu machen in
Zeiten von Corona haben wir das versucht
es ist einigen gelungen manchen auch
nicht gelungen es war eine
experimentelle Zeit aber es ist Rätsel
mehr möglich dass wir den Sinn die
Funktion den Bedeutung eines
universitätseminars auch virtuell
erzählen ohne uns
zum Beispiel Person
hat heute nicht geklappt lag aber in
meinen Augen daran dass sich die Leute
nicht an die Regeln gehalten haben wenn
man die Regel eben so erlassen
einschalten
physische Bücherei virtuelle Bücherei
meine physischen Bücherei wenn sie da
einmal ein Buch sich ausleihen es gibt
vielleicht fünf Exemplare
wenn sie dann ihren Kaffee zu schütten
auf diese physischen
einem virtuellen Bücherei können sie
sich prinzipiell dieses Buch zu oft
ausleihen wie Sie wollen es ist nicht
physisch begrenzt und Sie können es auch
nicht verlieren hast passiert sicherlich
dass man mal zu Hause verliert schlecht
sagen wie der Bibliothek aber jetzt
kriegen sie eine Woche Verlängerung
bezahlt
bei einem digitalen dienen virtuellen
passiert das nicht sie können einfach
nicht mehr zugreifen das ist ein ganz
andere Logik nicht so dass sie da etwas
übertragen bekommen
die Funktion ist aber die selbe sie
leiden sich etwas gegen Geld was sie am
Ende nicht besitzt das nicht in ihr
Eigentum übergeht ja dass sie besitzen
ist schon eine Weile sofern aber es geht
mir Eigentum
übertragen
zeitgebundenes ein zeitgebunden Zugang
zu einem Medium
eine Buch oder was auch immer haben sie
auf eine neue Weise digital realisiert
und das wäre nach meinem Begriffen eine
Virtualisierung des Prinzips des
verleihens des Bücher Lions oder
Bücherei ähnlich vielleicht nicht genau
dasselbe ein gedrucktes universales
wer von ihnen hat noch ein Brockhaus zu
Hause stehen ja mein Vater hat noch so
ein ganz Album 1900 so ein zwei Meter
natürlich total veraltet nur noch aus
historischen Interesse relevant aber
schauen Sie mal der Druckhaus nimmt Raum
ein und Ihrem Regal und zwar jede Menge
wenn sie jetzt Wikipedia sich mal
anschauen das ist die freie
entzyklopädie
die gar keinen Raum ein und sie veraltet
mich sie wird immer aktuell gehalten der
Brockhaus veraltet nach fünf Jahren
braucht seine neue Aufladen
man könnte jetzt sagen
wikipedia ist eine virtuelle Form
bitte und zwar eben kommen damit neue
Eigenschaften ins Spiel zum Beispiel
können Sie bei Wikipedia ja auch vor
laborativ an den Artikeln zu den
Artikeln Beitrag beim Brockhaus haben
Sie irgendwelche Autorin Autoren
fachexpertin Fachexperten idealerweise
bei Wikipedia können Sie jeden Artikel
diskutieren idealerweise nicht weil
natürlich Wikipedia auch gewissen
sozialen
Restriktion unterlegt und dann gibt's
natürlich auch ohne machen ne möchte
nicht streiten aber vom Prinzip her ist
Wikipedia eine Reihe zu Klopapier
doppelte Hinsicht wir haben kostenlos
haben oder ausleihen
am besten und sie ist frei im Idealfall
was die Erstellung der Beiträge nämlich
frei meines verhandeln dieser ob das
gelingt ist eine andere Frage von
Prinzip her ist es aber schon ein gutes
Prinzip und jetzt kann man sich fragen
ist YouTube eine Frau wirklich fern
oder schauen sich lieber Youtube an ich
will ihn jetzt auch nicht zu nahe treten
ich schaue eigentlich nicht mehr fern
und ich muss auch sagen wenn ich fern
schaue dann sehe ich da häufig das auf
Fernseher in Hotels ich habe nämlich
keinen Fernseher und dann sehe ich der
Fernseher ist schon eine halbe Computer
weil der mir dann immer anzeigt was für
eine Sendung läuft direkt im Bild also
ich kenne fast keine Fernseher mehr die
nicht irgendwelche digitalen
Informationsmöglichkeiten integriert
haben und Youtube was ist der Vorteil
Youtube ich schaue das an was mich
interessiert ich bestimme idealerweise
selbst was ich sehen möchte im Fernsehen
läuft alles läuft nicht ja das Problem
natürlich bei youtube ist der
Algorithmus der mir automatisch
vorschlägt was ich als nächstes zu sehen
habe Stichwort die digitale filterblasen
wird
vielleicht kennen Sie von diesem Autorin
gewesen dass durch diese al Personen wir
in einer Blase gehalten werden und es
nur Dinge vorgeschlagen werden die wir
bei Google zum Beispiel bekommen die
auch unseren vorherigen Zukunft
passieren also nicht jeder bekommt weder
das selbe
Ergebnis sondern
die Person vorher gesucht hat google
hatte ein Profil des Nutzers der
Nutzerin auch dass sie natürlich
ökonomisch interessiert die jeweiligen
ökonomischen
Ergebnisse
wir können natürlich auch hochtragen
individualistisch manipuliert werden und
im Glauben gelassen wird dass wir sie
feiern
zu tun und in Wirklichkeit aber werden
ja wir haben gesehen es gibt
verschiedene Ansätze das herkömmliche
kulturelle Form des ja alles kulturelle
Form Banknoten Geld physisches
universitätsseminar physische Bücherei
dass die durch neue Medien durch neue
Technologien virtualisiert werden man
muss dazu sagen nicht jede
technologische Verbesserung ist
gleichbedeutend mit einer
Virtualisierung
Virtualisierung haben wir jetzt ganz
vorläufig bestimmt dadurch dass sie
gesagt haben es wird weniger warm
zeitlich abhängig zum Beispiel
virtuellen Bücherei sind nicht mehr von
den physischen Exemplar abhängig wir
können sie nicht verstanden wir können
sie nicht vergessen wir können sie nicht
zerstören der Zweck hingegen wird beide
also Virtualität bewahrt den Sex sie
realisiert denselben Zweck aber indem
sie nicht mehr so dieses zeitlich
physische
diesen Bereich der Reibung hat zum
Beispiel durch die Digitalisierung immer
unabhängiger wird von räumlicher
Begrenzung diese Unabhängigkeit ist in
positiver Hinsicht eine Freiheit zu
neuen Möglichkeiten es energieren als
auf diesen neuen Medien neue
Möglichkeiten wie zum Beispiel bei
Wikipedia wenn wir sehen dass wir
plötzlich selbst zu diesen Beiträgen
beitragen können selbst ist diskutieren
können und wenn wir sehen dass diese
Enzyklopädie permanent aktuell gehalten
wird und nicht alle paar Jahre einer
neuen Auflage
mit allen Problemen die natürlich auch
damit einhergehen wie
Manipulation war und fehlende
Objektivität des Wissens das ist
natürlich auch Gefahren die durch diese
Qualität entstehen wird oder
virtualisiert ist nicht aus ethischer
Sicht unbedingt eine Verbesserung
sondern sie ist zwei schneidig die kann
so Verbesserung unserer Interaktion
beitragen zum moralischen verbessern
aber auch zu Verschlechterung es hängt
immer davon wie wir diese Medien
brauchen
so nachdem wir jetzt uns angenäht haben
durch konkrete Beispiele möchte ich
jetzt auf den begriffsgeschichtlichen
Aspekt eingehen wir hatten gesehen bei
ready Player one der Protagonist steigt
hinab und das die die Auto Gruft die
letzte Ordnung auf dieser historischen
realitätswelt und es gibt jetzt hier ein
Bild von David
aus seinem Buch reality Platz ich stelle
Ihnen das den nächsten Ausführungen vor
wenn Sie genau hinschauen sehen Sie play
dohs
wir sehen also ein Keller eigentlich wie
bei ready Player sie sehen ein Keller wo
Leute sitzen und fast schon
Schattenbilder sehen die aber eingegeben
werden bei ready Player one wird es
nicht eingegeben der wird selbst
interagiert vergleichen Sie das jetzt
mal mit diesem Gemälde was er auch das
platonische höhengleichnis zeigt das
sehen Sie die Mauer oben sehen Sie die
Figuren von links kommt das Licht ist
das Licht und da werden Schattenbilder
an die Wand geworfen die werden für die
eigentliche Möglichkeit gehalten dieses
platonische Gleichnis wird immer gerne
bemüht wenn es um virtuelle Realität
geht meistens so bemüht dass man sagt
virtuelle Realität ist nur dieses
schaffen ja also das ist dann dieser
Simulation wir haben bisher gesehen dass
das zu kurz greifen wenn man nämlich
Virtualität im Sinne
steht dann greift dieser bloß simulative
Aspekt zu kurz ich bin also sehr
skeptisch Platon so für virtuelle
Realität zu benutzen lieber sollten wir
nicht das Höhlengleichnis nehmen sondern
das Linien gleichens und uns mal fragen
das natürlich aus der virtuellen
Enzyklopädie Wikipedia und uns mal
fragen wo ist hier die virtuelle
Realität einzuordnen sie kennen dieses
Onkologie
also rechts hier das sind die
verschiedenen Vermögen also ein Kasia
für Wahrheiten für eine Wahrnehmung ja
ist das diskussive Bestehen durch
abgeleitet ist Folge und die neue
Systeme
es muss in die Wahrheit und die
Realitäten Idee
wir sehen es beginnt mit bloßen
Schattenbildern sie können das schon
abbilden ob das höhengleichnis die
Wahrheiten der Bilder der Schattenbilder
für die eigentlichen Bilder und wie weit
es sie aus der Hölle hinaussteigen ans
Tageslicht treten und dann die Sonne
sehen umso mehr
Ideen und jetzt kann man sich natürlich
fragen wo ist die Virtualität hier
anzuziehen die gängige Meinung wurde
sagen unten alles was du mit einer Szene
sind nur ein Spiegelbild
[Musik]
ich glaube wird schon Realität
verstanden als
Alternative realisierungsweise von
herkömmlichen Praktiken Prozessen Dingen
muss weiter oben werden vielleicht sogar
in einem ganzen neuen Bereich
den heiligend wäre hier sogar die Idee
vielleicht auch einzusetzen ist
natürlich ziemlich unplattform aber
diese Frage muss man sich stellen meine
These ist virtuelle Realitäten sind
nicht hier unten Bilder auch nicht ein
sinnlich wahrnehmbare Gegenstände auch
nicht als mathematische Gegenstände
platonischen Ideen eher dazwischen
zwischen mathematischen Gegenständen und
Ideen zu finden wie zum Beispiel Werte
von machen ja eine sozialkonstituierte
Realität das macht sie aber deswegen
nicht gleich
zu irgendwo oder dazwischen und zwar im
Sinne einer sozialontologie oder einer
technikontologie das heißt die Ideen
existiert nach Platon so diese die sind
einfach ewige Wesenheiten so verhält es
sich natürlich mit virtuellen Realität
nicht das sind keine ewigen Wesenheiten
wenn sie erinnern auch nicht zahlen die
ewig existieren dann virtuelle
Realitäten hängt von der Technik ab und
von unserer subjektiven
kommunikationieren werden gesehen haben
die sind aber keine Sinn ich war das
heißt man könnte sich überlegen
vielleicht dazwischen zwischen
mathematischen Gegenständen
ja also spannende Frage wo gehört die
virtuelle Realität hier reicht nicht
jedenfalls zu meine These bei den
Abbildungen das müssen wir uns wirklich
mal fragen
genügend die platonische Onkologie
überhaupt und die epistologie um diese
virtuelle Realität angemessen zu fassen
oder fällt dir etwas aus dem Rahmen der
platonischen Anthologie das wäre auch
eine mögliche
da müssen wir aber dann morgen genau
darüber diskutieren wenn es um die
Ontologie geht jetzt komme ich auch den
nächsten Kandidaten zu sprechen in der
Begriffsgeschichte das sind die übrigen
üblichen Verdächtigen das ist
Aristoteles also bei Platon kümmern uns
fragen virtuelle Realität ist es eine
Sache von großen Schein wahrscheinlich
oder ist es etwas höherstufiges was
vielleicht in Richtung Idee geben
Aristoteles ist jetzt nicht so wichtig
die Frage Schein Erscheinung Idee
gewesen sein sondern die Unterscheidung
von Modalitäten
Aristoteles wie sie alle wissen
unterscheidet zwischen Wirklichkeit
Möglichkeit und Notwendigkeit
das heißt er unterscheidet zwischen
verschiedenen Formen wie die Dinge
existieren können und diese Form können
wir auch virtuelle Realität beziehen es
virtuelle Realität wirklich offenbar
schon ähm wie verhält sich dabei aber zu
Möglichkeiten die Möglichkeit scheint
bei der virtuellen Realität ein ganz
wichtige Rolle zu spielen weil sie ja
neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet indem es ja
bezogen ist auf ein physischen gestanden
der gerade zu wenig Möglichkeiten bietet
also wir müssen hier Wirklichkeit und
Möglichkeit bei virtueller Realität in
einer ganz engen dynamischen Beziehung
den
Aristoteles und Platon hatten den
Begriff der virtuellen Realitäten und
nicht begrifflich gefasst wir nutzen
hier nur Grundbegriffe ihre Philosophie
anders verhält sich jetzt wenn wir einen
Blick in dieses historische Wörterbuch
der Philosophie werden genauer gesagt im
Band 11 wo es um die Buchstaben oder die
extreme von oben bis VGV Virtualität
oder virtuell und da lesen jetzt
folgendes und der weder der antiken
Philosophie noch Rechtswissenschaft
bekannt gewesen auszuwirken will und
lateinisch wird das
gesehen der Kraft nach ist der in der
lateinischen philosophischen Technologie
einer der Gegenbegriffe zu förmlich und
bezieht sich auf das Verhältnisse
Ursachen und Wirkung okay das Verhältnis
von Ursachen wird häufig ein dynamisches
verhält
und in diese dynamischen Verhältnisse
fließen immer auch Modalität
Wirklichkeit Möglichkeit also ganz
wichtig Virtualität hat mit Kausalität
was zu tun und deswegen natürlich auch
mit Kraft
das wiederum spricht dagegen virtuelle
Realität nur als Bose Simulation
Illusion anzusehen da wäre der
kraftaspekt nicht genügend
berücksichtigt und jetzt gehen wir mal
schön mit einem großen Sprung von
Aristoteles ins finstere oder doch nicht
so finstere Mittelalter zu Thomas von
Aquin der hat im 13 jahrhundert gelebt
und der so liest man jetzt in diesem
Artikel historischen Wörterbuch der
unterscheidet zwischen dem virtuellen
den essentiellen die Materialen und
Aktoren
S 1 Virtualität das virtuelle
Material und die aktuellen System
wirklichen vorliegenden Sinne dem
faktisch vorliegenden unterschieden
werden
könnte man denken wenn das virtuelle
aktualisieren wird
Wirklichkeit zu tun dann wäre es
vielleicht doch eher im Sinne der bösen
Illusion Unmöglichkeiten zu sehen
vielleicht ist es nicht wir hatten ja
gesehen virtualisiert hat was mit Kraft
zu tun also es ist nicht das aktualis
das wirklich was wir normalerweise
finden
übertragen jetzt das physisch wirkliche
sondern es ist eine Form von
Wirklichkeit die diesen aktuellen
nachgeordnet ist auf eine ganz besondere
Weise nicht im Sinne des essentiellen
dem das wesenhaften sondern im Sinne
einer neuen Form von Realisierung die
eben Möglichkeiten ich gebe ein Beispiel
man liest von Thomas Hunger Queen dass
eine Wirkung B
virtuell in der wirkursachen enthalten
kann
ist virtuell der Wirkung sein
das sagt Thomas
weiter sagte die Wirkung B ist effektiv
bzw virtuell in der Ursache enthalten
als effektiv heißt
kausal wirksam
[Musik]
als Armut deswegen weil es im Arsch
irgendwie angelegt war sonst könnte es
ja daraus folgen
sie sehen effektiv wirksam und virtuell
sind nach Thomas
austauschbar oder zumindest sehr sehr
ähnlich wie ihre Bedeutung und das
wiederum
entlastete Begriff der Virtualität von
den Verdacht der bloßen
Fake Welt der bloß Simulationen
ist ist auch eine ontologische Relevanz
wo ist diese Effizienz nicht so zu
verstehen wie eine
normale politische materielle
Wirklichkeit wir sehen das wird wenn es
zu Materialien unterschieden werden als
es hat irgendwie was schon leicht
begeistertes die sich Material aber es
ist doch wirklich
wegbewegung transzenden Material
gebundenen wirklichen etwas immer drehen
aber dennoch kausalwirksam und das liegt
auch ganz auf unsere Linie dass wir
sagen virtuelle Realität ist real ist
außerwechsel aber ist immer mehr
losgelöst von dem physischen Material
wirklich existieren der physischen
Realität
jetzt müssen wir natürlich wieder auf
einen virtuelle Realität virtuelle
Enzyklopädie eingehen nämlich Artikel
Virtualität ich kann so viel sagen der
ist nicht manipuliert worden ich sehe
auch keine kommerziellen Interessen man
muss abwarten vielleicht irgendwann
Apple hier auch gleich noch in den
Artikel Virtualität ein Link zu Apple
Vision pro reinmachen und sagt virtuelle
Realität bekommen Sie nur mit der 3.500
€ Brille aber noch ist sowas hier nicht
zu entnehmen wohl auch nicht der
Diskussion Zeit gehe ich jetzt davon aus
was sagt jetzt Wikipedia Virtualität ist
die Eigenschaften einer Sache nicht in
der Form zu existieren in der sie zu
existieren scheint
aber ihren Wesen ihre Wirkung einer in
dieser Form existierenden Sachen
zugleich
Virtualität bezeichnet als eine gedacht
Entität die ihre Funktionalität oder
wirken Verhalten ist
nicht in der forms existieren und der
sie zu existieren scheint aber von dem
Wesen der Wirkung
ist
das gleiche Funktion der Zweck ist
derselbe
physische Bibliothek ausleihbibliothek
und virtuelle Bibliothek der funktioner
ist es genau dasselbe aber es wird auf
eine andere Weise reduziert eben mit dem
ursprünglichen Begriff der
auslagebibliothek der physischen nichts
mehr zu tun
so würde sich auf jeden Fall ein Sinn
ergeben die Funktionalität ist von der
Wirkung hätte dieselbe
ich will mir einen ausleihen das kann
ich auch in der Wirtschaft machen nur
eben nicht mehr in physisches Exemplar
immer noch ein bisschen weiter auf
gottfried Wilhelm Leibnitz so ist
ich habe gestern mal ein bisschen
nachgestöbert in seinen Schritten man
muss da wirklich lange suchen findet
oder natürlich was französisch ist
versteht alle Französisch muss nicht
sein wir haben natürlich die Deutschen
die Ideen und Wahrheiten sind uns
eingeboren als Neigungen Anlagen
Fertigkeiten oder natürlich
nicht aber als
Tätigkeiten und gleich diese Kräfte
immer von gewissen auf unmerklichen
Tätigkeiten welche entsprechend
er spricht jetzt hier
Übersetzung von Virtualität natürlich
ist natürliche Kräfte also Virtualität
ist hier als Kraft bezeichnet
das passt mit dem was wir bisher gesehen
haben schon gut zu sagen
also bei Thomas von Aquin hatten wir
gesehen dass es das Baby Wirkung
virtuelle der Ursache einhalten und es
hat was mit Kraft zu tun
hier spricht er jetzt von natürlichen
Kräfte
also Virtualität so viel kann man daraus
entnehmen Virtualität hat nichts mit
bloßes Simulation oder Illusion
das hat irgendwie eine Relevanz
wie genau diese kausale Relevanz zu
verstehen ist das ist jetzt eine andere
Frage ich habe noch ein Zitat
wahre Urteile sind dann virtuelle
identisch wenn man sie durch
begriffliche Analyse auf formalen
Identitäten zurückführen kann
was meint er hierfür
verurteilen durch begrifflich Analyse
sie wissen bleiben zwar auch an Logiker
und er meint hier wohl wenn ich ihn
rechts verstehe so viel wie analytische
urteilen alle Junggesellen sind und
verheiratet
das ist jetzt auf den ersten Blick
schon irgendwie Einsiedler aber
natürlich in Junggeselle ist jetzt
unmittelbar nicht gleich dasselbe wie
ein
verheiratet haben Mensch wenn wir aber
die Begriffe weiter analysieren stellen
wir sehr schnell fest dass es eben auf
Intensität zurückzubringen ist deswegen
ist dieses Urteil alle Junggesellen sind
unverheiratet analytisch nach kantabiori
analytisch vor aller erfahren
aber es ist eben trivial ja dieses
dieses Satz sagt uns nichts dieses hat
sagt uns am Ende nur gleich an alle
Jungen sind unverheiratet heißt
Junggeselle ist ja unverheiratete ein
unverheiratet junge Mann ist
unverheiratet ja gleich ah also wir
können es am Ende auch formal
Identitäten Arzt eine formal Identität
gleich zurückbringen ja sie sind
virtuelle identisch weil sie eben nicht
direkt als solche identisch schon Sätze
oder Begriffe verständlich sind
Junggeselle und verheiratet im
Junggesellen steckt nicht direkt treten
verheiratet muss ich erst analysieren
werden also ich habe einen anderen
Begriff und das meinte jetzt mit
virtuitiv
also nicht unmittelbar identische
vermittelt
also das virtuelle wird ja auch
irgendwas von
Vermittlung und sich aber dennoch von
Identität es ist also nicht die
unmittelbar sichtbare Identität das wäre
vielleicht ja dann ist die verwickelter
ja ich muss das erst analysieren eine
komplexere
Identität die bedacht und so kann man es
wieder zurückziehen auch das was wir
bereits gesehen haben
Virtualität ist effektiv ist wirklich
aber eben nicht so wirklich wie es
normalerweise unmittelbar zum Beispiel
physisch wirklich ist
es ein bisschen kompliziert
so könnte man jetzt versuchen das Ganze
zusammen zu bringen immer noch mal auf
Emanuel
er hat natürlich auch
lateinisch schreiben können sie können
natürlich alle Dateien schließen
deswegen nehmen wir hier gleich noch die
deutsche Übersetzung mit dazu er sagt in
seiner Schrift die mundi sensibel ist
für intelligibles forma expliziert ist
seine Dissertation über die Form und die
Prinzipien der Sinnes und Geisteswelt
aus dem Jahr 177
[Musik]
und 40 46 erst 24
aber eben nicht räumlich als sie im
materielles soll eben virtuell
der Übersetzer dieser Schrift hat das
mit dynamisch er hat virtuell virtuelles
als dynamisch übersetzen ich habe
natürlich gleich draus gemacht virtuell
kann man sich natürlich fragen wie das
zu verstehen ist aber es bringt wieder
ein weiterer Bestandteil unser Konzept
von Virtualität oder virtuelle Realität
virtuell existiert etwas wenn es
existiert nicht räumlich ausgeht nicht
körperlich aber dennoch existiert ist
das ergibt Sinn ja
rituales nun Lokal wo existieren
Bitcoins existieren die in dem Rechner
wo er gemeint wird wo existieren die
Frage ist eigentlich sinnlos sie
existieren irgendwie in der Welt aber
nicht so dass ich sie lokalisieren kann
wie ein 10 € scheintisch weil sie nicht
Material ist
existieren vielleicht bei einer
Festplatte könnte man sagen vielleicht
sie kennen den Fall wo jemand meine
Festplatte entsorgt hat aus Versehen wo
sie noch einige Bitcoins kaufen
aber wo genau existieren sie sind 0 und
1 es sind vielleicht bestimmte Bereiche
auf der Festplatten aber diese Angabe
eines festplattenbereichs er ist nicht
eine räumliche Angabe es ist eher eine
logisch
die Partition die Orte auf einer
Festplatte sind logischen Orte weniger
räumliche
es kann sein dass eine Null und eine
eins auf eine ganz andere Seite der
Festplatte ist und freue mich trotzdem
gehört die zusammen sie sehen diese
normale zeitlogen zumindest die greift
hier so nicht mehr weil virtuellen
Realität und zum Schluss des kurzen
historischen begriffsgeschichten
Überblicks
kommen wir auch unterwegs zu sprechen
der ist schon deutlich jünger der ist
eigentlich in der Zeit des deutschen
internismus beheimatet und er sagt jetzt
folgendes die Entstehung des Lebens aber
ist virtuell nicht sinnlich eben
deswegen ist sie durch keinen
Mechanismus und keinen chemischen
Prozess zu erklären das Leben ist auch
einmal da in dem Moment in welchem in
der absoluten Virtualität Kraft und
Gegenkraft einander
begegnen müssen
das Leben ist deswegen wird schnell und
es ist insofern virtuell und Entstehung
als sie nicht mechanisch und chemisch
erklärt werden kann aber ziemlich
mystisch ne ist jetzt hier nach
unterwegs das virtuelle nur ein
Besiedlung nicht weiter erklärbare
mystische Phänomene
sagt noch was anderes tierische
Virtualität ist blinde Subjektivität das
Tier handelt denn es hat Vorstellungen
aber es handelt durchaus Objektiv das
heißt determiniert durch reizt sein
Wille ist bloßer trieb oder blinde
Bestreben so wie sich aber ein Strahl
der Vernunft in der Virtualität zeigt
findet das Streben des Subjekt sich frei
Virtualität wird hier auf jeden Fall
positiv konnotiert und es wird auch im
Sinne etwas
Begriffes eine geistige
körpergeistige Größe die nicht durch
Mechanismus und chemische Analyse
beschrieben werden kann etwas Geistiges
und etwas was auch eine gewisse nee zur
Vernunft hat und zu Bewusstsein hat und
auch zum zur Freiheit also Virtualität
hier als geistige Größe
würde insofern wieder unser Konzept
passen als wir Virtualität oder
virtuelle Realität nur dann erreichen
wenn wir gewisse kulturelle Grundlagen
bereits haben nur kulturell schaffende
Wesen wie wir Menschen sind vielleicht
auch manche nicht menschlichen Tiere
kann man darüber diskutieren über
Delfine nur die können überhaupt sowas
wie virtuelle Realität jetzt Vorbringen
weil sie über diese Freiheit haben diese
Freiheit verfügen sich von der
physischen Realität zu lösen und etwas
auf eine neue Form kausal zu realisieren
finde ich ein ganz interessant natürlich
verwendet diese herunterweg ähm
Virtualität in ganz verschieden
Hinsichten nicht immer ganz hilfreich
aber wenn man sie anschauen
Virtualität hat eine gewisse geistige
die mit intellektualistische Dimension
und es würde wirklich gut in meinen
Augen hineinpassen die bisherige
Begriffsgeschichte nicht das unmittelbar
physisch vorliegende seine Kausalität
die nicht direkt vorliegt wie bei diesem
analytischen Urteil sind verwickelt
entwickelt werden muss und die dadurch
auch eine gewisse geistige Dimension
erhält die nicht nur mechanisch oder
chemisch
deterministisch gewissermaßen
expliziert werden kann das in seiner
Idee eine Apotheke aus dem Jahr 1799
enthalten ja da haben wir jetzt die
ganze Menge von ja nicht immer ganz
aufeinander passenden
Begriffsbestimmungen erhalten ich glaube
aber dass man sie gut aufeinander
beziehen kann ich fast noch mal zusammen
Virtualität hat was mit Kausalität zu
tun Virtualität hat etwas zu tun mit
Kraft Virtualität hat etwas zu tun mit
Verwickeltheit mit fehlender
Unmittelbarkeit das war dieses
analytische Urteil das ist
herausgeglaubt werden muss wie kann ich
sagen würde und Virtualität hat etwas zu
tun mit Vergeistigung und auch mit
Freiheit und mit kultureller Entwicklung
was eben nicht nur deterministisch
naturwissenschaftlich beschrieben werden
ja das ist natürlich schon eine recht
philosophische Bestimmungen Virtualität